[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it's
Christmas today it's Christmas today is
it today I think conceptually are they
watching this at midnight I don't know
how they count it I don't understand you
open presents did Santa come Merry
Christmas holol Even if it's a day after
Mary we don't even know what's time what
does it matter it's the season of giving
today is the day Jesus was born
scientifically speaking they woke up he
said what up Jesus ladies and gentlemen
we don't know the episode title that's
how been going into these is it about
Jesus no what if Jesus was in the MCU
you know what to do uh leave a like that
would be very much appreciated also tell
us in the comments you've seen this
episode before we have what did you
think about it did you like it where
would you rank it what is your what if
Christmas scenario subscribe and click
that notification get notified when our
reaction for the next episodes up on the
channel we are powering through them
thank you to pra for helping us edit
down these highlights you guys don't
deserve a day off thank you to all who
have joined us at our patreon page you
comeing super sex to rejects or there
you get the full length reaction
watchong where you sync up with your own
copy of what if and John and I cover
several things over there exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs
included Kon you ready to all a good
night Heroes plucked from across
different realities previously on of all
of them season one but you don't know
her story oh from the daughter of a Mad
Titan to the champion of a multiversal
war oh that's cool to becoming the hero
of her story began in someone
else's they're doing a continuation of a
of an episode season one that's an
interesting all right all right a a
hidden sequel episode they're really
being ambitious and and bold with their
formatting yes ambitious I'm going to
call it ambitious with his home on the
verge of Destruction Tony Stark
self-made Iron Man made the ultimate
Heroes play that's a different universe
that's hard Universe yeah that's not the
what universe but in this universe Tony
never made it her
ah oh that's sad that is dark Oh I
thought they just killed him
off oh he lands with the uh we're
goingon to beet Jeff Goldblum again crap
I'm dead people at sakar the Grand
Master Can't Be Heaven uh I think that's
sakar you're not
God
yeah okay who wo W uh-oh fire topaz the
foam release the
[Music]
[__] I think it was Overkill with the
foam but look he's still smoldering uh
no this is hell I've gone to
hell this is you this is you this is the
guy Mr metal Mojo man is in the palace
oh this going to be the Mad Max episode
I think so yes the defeat of Thanos and
provocateur with the facial hair I like
what you're doing with defeater of
Thanos you know time works differently
here we've been talking about Mr metal
Mojo man's nuclear ride for for
days possibly Tin Man Rocket Man Mojo
man it is
okay the Mojo I like that metal Mojo cuz
you do have oh we won good a some good
heart she's okay she's okay okay
Mojo oh I like that attention of detail
there they gave him a moment I like it
actually give some nuance you got to
stay and celebrate with us it's my uh
21st 21st what
birthday but thanks but I kind of put my
party days behind me so spaceship is it
uh that way whoever's playing Iron Man
does a great job really
solid uh will there be food like I can
hear where it's off but they nail the
type of tone and
intonation the Rhythm Is there yeah
that's more important than a sound alike
celebrate two things me and and the
SAR I thought this was going to be
Gamora story oh yeah maybe she wins the
race Valkyrie yay
get
and hang like Mario Kart jump the
go not yet not
yet it's
fantastic oh my
God corg
get out of here you crazy
[Applause]
kid oh I love the sound design that tast
like a dog park surprise it's me I
didn't mean to Spook you or did I I did
I
did that must be him I think it's Jeff
goia yep you got it nailed it yeah well
this would be called a chariot race
Formula 1 this is Intergalactic
NASCAR uh race cars are similar but very
different common mistake don't be
embarrassed whoa going on Zack Snider on
us damn grandm and Tony Stark
interacting good call delightful that's
what you use Whata if for the things
that we can never have woo
cool it's like ready player one
yeah
whoa
offense someone with the celestial
face celestials but small fitting end
for who was
that this is
horrifying H that old
trick
you look dazzled by her
Tony you're going to miss the best part
hey throw the tin cans at
[Applause]
her o I'd like to see you old drive
isn't this a touch barbaric no that's
part of the joy of it it's like a
gladiator battle are those pamsters topz
chinam Cal your cheeks we used to throw
rotten food but given the recent famines
leaving people uh how do I put this
peckish peckish if you liked my
chinchillas you're going to love my
Champion release the champion oh who's
it going to be this
[Music]
corg what who is this this guy there he
is
[Music]
nothing it's actually a great shot bro
no here's the best part oh no so much
for staying for one drink oh you're
doing the thing he's doing the
thing I do miss the suit
UPS cuz now it's all like uh why is it
sticky nanot Tech yeah and it's all
smooth and liquid not
suie the extremist era not the
same you to think this through
Tony
[Music]
Valkyrie do that Gamora yeah it supposed
to be a Gamora story yeah Gamora yeah
does he build her a hot rod cuz Tony's
whole thing was like hot rods and
cars gun
aler oh cuz she's
Thanos she would be on thanos's side
after the events so like this would be
an actual fight who are you you're
death thank you very very much you've
ruined my birthday that's sarcasm the
first part not the second
part perfect I feel like valky is
attracted to Gamora
oh
woke perk of having an arc reactor in
your chest why are you trying to kill me
daughter of Thanos the one burdened to
bring balance to this universe daughter
of Thanos he doesn't know about Thanos
yet right right CU Avengers all right
ready to ride roll I had to say that at
least once not you stabby he sensed it
remember he had that feeling and we saw
him turn around at the end of Avengers
but he didn't have a name for him all
right wait for my signal say no
more I love that just made him a Hulk oh
Tony Tony Tony you blinked on no planet
is that a signal Tony I thought I saw
your goatee twitch no Tony you
blinked she got to gun you again would
you glare your way out of that cell oh
it'll take take more than laser prooof
glass to Rob Thanos of his victory pick
a new
song The Way theyve edited I can't tell
if these guys recorded in the same booth
or not because they they've edited them
together really well at least the
comedic timing is real yeah did we date
or something what your dad got against
me you destroyed his tatari New
York your Victory might have been
glorious but it will also be short
people died I lost a friend do you know
what it's like to see your home world
destroyed she knows she knows she knows
she more than most almost brought to its
knees by a mad man you're saying all the
things there won't be a next time he's
talking to Terence
Howard next time baby Mojo man he's not
the hero we hope he's a very nasty nasty
man put down your dinner I mean that is
if you got food is this Grandmaster guy
as bad as my gut says he is he use me as
a paper weight just have to sit on paper
which is my
nemesis
the running theme of paper rock and then
I'm going after your
dad how did she get out her story of
Gamora is before her Avengers episode in
what season one right yes it have to be
look at this little thing I think I'll
name him NCO after my friend Jeffrey
you're the revengers yeah you were in a
Death Race here to explain I was going
to win sure you were what happened to
last year's winner oh he went to live on
a farm with the other winners
you want the thrill to feel alive so you
can forget whatever mistake has you
chasing that demon in a bottle demon in
the bottles the Iron Man story where
he's an alcoholic that's clever cuz
we're going to beat the grandmas at his
own game what do you say it is cool to
hear Tony Stark say demon in the bottle
and thanks for that Mar I'm seeing the
character of just Tony Stark and not
just like some what if came yeah hey did
I try any silly
stuff that is the silly stuff
yeah more montages building stuff we
didn't get to see Valkyrie and Tony
interact huh what's cool is that it does
feel like they've brought Tony St to
life you know and I'm getting I feel
like I'm getting my wish fulfillment of
Tony yeah you shouldn't be here you
should be running ever hear of
Campground rules always leave a place
better than you found it but since it's
an made it and it's not Downy it doesn't
feel like it sacrifices our universes
yeah exactly people creatures beings of
SAR have seen enough Insanity here's my
offer me you One race winner takes the
planet bad pack I'm intrigued but not
sold you pick the Chariots sir there's
no reason to do this H up don't be such
a logic
Linda logic Linda if I win I get that
suit uh deal you're racing too mopet of
Thanos it's daughter of Thanos daughter
really I'll stick to that story
too they set this up I was going to be
the one part that's kind of lacking for
me in this episode is they set up as
like a Gamora origin of that version of
her yeah and it's doesn't feel like that
at all well I that's the third act I'm
assuming but definitely not what it felt
like like I like the episode but excuse
like what we it's why have that in the
opening yeah yeah like what a roundabout
way to be like and Iron Man landed here
like just do that come to take this off
me depends still going to kill me that's
what I thought here let's keep in
touch have a nice summer this is what I
like I really feel like I'm watching
Iron Man again it's actually pretty
exciting it's pretty exciting
yeah for me wait for my queue
[Music]
go
cool now nice very Mad
Max use a little the doof
Warrior take that nice cool corg is like
the heart of the Season he really
is yeah oh great tracking shot damn
that's so much fun there's like a cool
action shot in every episode yeah they
really deed this season it's actually
got flavor who are you cuz all I hear
about is your father I'm a murderous
thank you yeah yeah that was yesterday
what about today what about right now
it's a great question okay so they are
tied in koi okay it's coming back I told
you third act here we
are Rainbow Road celestials mouth
[Music]
tongue ouchie
what is this tire the tires The Chariot
yeah this makes no sense how do you see
oh you're alive never been
happier oh hold up there lady Grinch
could use a little help hold
up how does he see I don't know I can't
get
it
oh no no no no no no no
fly Commander another Chariot turn into
a hot rod
yeah that's what I wanted that was cool
there is what I wanted that is awesome
that was awesome I was want hot rod this
whole time like an action figure he just
transform go to Target and you get like
an Iron Man car they need many toys of
this that's all I wanted now I'm happy I
was that was my my only negative and now
I'm good I'm so
[Music]
good I love how they kept that kind of
80s sci-fi synth music yeah like sakar
had in the movie I lived in my dad's
Shadow for a long time I did stuff I'm
not proud
of people died because of who I was and
what I fil I like how they they have
this attention to detail the characters
great but I'm not my father you're not
your father I made a choice for the
better and I became Iron Man you mean Mr
metal Mojo oh I see that
sticking I feel like the
characterization of our leads that we've
known for three phases is better here
than in Phase 4 in the live action cuz
Thor didn't feel like Thor and like
Doctor Strange didn't either oh
beautiful right
like like the writing here is so good to
these
[Applause]
characters oh
[Music]
uh anyway you get to decide who you want
to be not your father not your past you
decide who are you why safe my name is
[Music]
Gamora why is
Gamora wow destroying Titans that was
cool is that Dutch Swedish mayy this
isn't over
Stark golden red hot roded making me so
happy oh and she's going to win and then
she'll be the queen of the planet so
Tony can leave ah yes yes I was
wondering why Valkyrie had to race but
it's so she can
win and that way she's a leader of new
valky and new Asgard all over
again oh no that was wronged wronged
wrong I'm winning I'm
[Music]
winning yeah that's right American
Innovations 180
mph excellent
[Applause]
shot the tow
ring Play
Dirty there it
is
[Music]
yeah Iron Man
powered awesome awesome he had to hit
the NOS yeah he did it too soon
Junior that's a 10-second car
great it's got the SAR markings but it's
Iron Man
I think there's like actually great
technical achievements in this for
animation for Marvel a tie and as the
rulle St the choice of winner comes down
to me I choose me get boo
[Music]
boo hey I like it
o that feels
good viscous oh he smells like bad Life
Choices it was smart to make Grand
Master the
actual villain of this yeah and they
finally like killed the what if
character hey she's still the one
celebrated hey and she's going to be
taking down the Tyrant she's going to be
asgard's new Asgard
Queen and she's doing the walk I think
they just cred you their King what do
you say about the being special counsel
to the king yep okay I'll do that so
close to home his Odyssey almost at an
end except oh I can't return to my
father Without You Stark it's not the
punches thrown but the people that
change the outcome of the battle what
you never failed to amaze me little one
you're the one they call Iron Man what
someone finally got your name right
let's do this G it's knowing someone has
your back in a
fight
I'm
melting all
right I don't know how I feel about the
Thanos Saga being n and void by a single
attack but I mean that's what what if
does that's true that's you got to carry
on the what if
tradition you're not wrong you know what
other tradition people should carry on
What's That getting themselves some RR
apparel this the space babies of the
Galaxy or Marvel inspired shirt Coy's
got a whole bunch of shirts and he's
choosing to pull out that one that I'm
already wearing and flashed on camera
and look pull that one you know here's
just some photos on screen because we
got like our you know Pedro Pascal space
babies of the Galaxy Coy I'm trying to
shout out whoa whoa oh I'm so glad
you're here hey could you find a bucket
bucket and a mop sponge me sponge me up
I need to be absorbed by
something looks handrawn that was
fantastic gross looks like cheese oh I
like that last one it's the house of the
Dragon one my favorite of the Game of
Thrones yeah these were all handpicked
by Greg for me for Christmas yeah buddy
we also got our Pedro Pascal one that
everyone loves so much and a whole bunch
of other ones and we saw some Marvel
apparel as well but yeah guys it's
personally my favorite way you can go
ahead and supp support the channel you
look good while doing it and we're
involved with all the designs as well
what do you think of the episode it was
all the fun of uh of the Christmas one
for me but with a little bit more story
like it felt more like an important
issue like sometimes in comics issues
are fun and they serve the purpose of
like entertaining but you know it's not
going to really be like referenced So
when you say issue you mean like comic
book isue yeah yeah not like mental
issue yeah like like like an issue of
comics um I do find that like the fun
ones sometimes don't feel like they
further their plot and that's that's
okay like it doesn't bother me but this
episode felt like an actual what if
universe that there could be a sequel to
this felt like an issue that had some
weight tying into other issues while
also having the fun of the Christmas one
so I think this and the Christmas one
are almost like tied for me because I
didn't love the very very ending um but
Greg brought up an immediately good
point in that it is like a what if where
that is a great way to give it stakes
and and tie things in together and make
it have import but um I liked that the
bookends served that purpose where it
was like how does this really get to
Gamora and then you're like oh I'm
shocked they're bringing them and then
like it was a bit of a twist it was a
bit of a surprise so I liked it I forget
what the setup is of that Gamora in the
opening is is oh yeah I forget is she
like is her thing that she killed her
dad is that like her her setup with the
character they're not fighting Thanos
it's been three years it's been a while
right it's been a long time since what
if season 1 yeah I don't remember also
do you remember when they announced what
if season two they said everything was
going to relate to phase four and they
were like everything from fa like
remember they said season one was all of
phase 1 through three and then they're
like season two really focused on phase
four none of these have been about phase
four yet no not at all I wonder if they
like completely changed their plan after
it's a good call because uh so far it's
way better than season one I'm loving
this so much it's so much better than
season one I agree I I think on on every
level in terms of what I've really
wanted them to do was utilize animation
you know like when I watch The
Incredibles for the first time I
remember thinking oh at the time of of
when The Incredibles came out what they
were doing with demonstrating these
superhero Powers their overall prowess
you could only do an animation at the
time and make it feel believable because
you are being in the medium of Animation
as opposed to watching live action and
watching this Jos of something that
feels like a cartoon CGI thing and here
they're actually utilizing that with
their camera angles with a lot of these
great shots that might look a little bit
wonky in live action especially with the
time they all lot for their visual
effects artist a lot of the time and
yeah and pay so yeah I think that what
they've been doing here like with the
car racing sequences that have this like
Mad Max Mario Kart bit of like
uh in in the Star War I don't even watch
it but the Star Wars like animated shows
like tales of the Jedi it's not pod
racing there some called Riot racing I
think is what it called why would they
she pod race I mean it's cuz it's a
different kind of thing but it's the
same thing kind of thing like a baric
type of pod racing and and is sort of
the uh vibe that I have here but like
they have these sweeping angles and
precision on their editing that I
absolutely adore but that all can be
still I I think that could all be null
and void if you don't have an
interesting story and I think what they
are doing really well the only one that
kind of let me down a tad bit has been
episode 2 this one I thought it was so
smart to have the whole thing with the
heart of like missing pepper at the very
top that way they're reminding the
audience like no we haven't forgotten
about the characterization of what point
in time we are with this guy and what
would Tony be feeling I felt like I was
actually watching Tony start Carry On
from that first Avengers movie we got
Iron Man back and it wasn't in a way
that I felt like sacrificed the Iron Man
sacrifice yeah and that's so you mean
I've talked about that at nauseum I'm
I'm tired of mentioning my issues with
bringing back them multiv yeah
Multiverse things it doesn't you don't
bring back the the actor because your
brain's not going to go that's not my
Tony Stark you're going to go Robert
Tony Jr is Iron Man and this is managing
because it's a different medium to feel
like Iron Man and feel like the spirit
of Downey Jr brings us back to Avengers
one yeah it's so good it's really well
done and the way they pay attention to
their characters of How would how would
grandmas interact with Tony Stark or
vice versa how would Tony Stark interact
with Valkyrie how would he respond to to
cor I really feel like they
I get the impression the writers
actually love the characters they are
portraying here you know what at the
least they watch them at the very least
they watch them I feel like these people
watched all of w Division I get the
impression they actually like the
characters because they feel accurately
portrayed from the movies which is the
difference for me from what if season 1
to what if season 2 exactly what if
season 1 felt like they were making an
MCU thing to make it and season two has
felt like the comic books where it's
like a writer that loves a character has
a weird take they want to play with that
won't be in
they they felt like the very definition
not all the time but some of the time a
good amount of the time I would say of
when they were bringing over like a
character when they're bringing over
like a storyline or continuity from a
movie I'm not talking like strange
Supreme which is like a very different
that's a very very different take you
know um I'm talking about whenever they
would cut to Tony Stark in season one it
would often felt like a cameo or some
type of caricature it didn't feel like a
caricature and this felt like a
character and I I found myself getting
lost in it and just believing I'm
watching Tony Stark again and I think
the depth of Animation heightening is
allowing a little bit more imersive cuz
like we're like more in like this
animation is stunning it's so much
better and I don't know how people think
it's the same because it's it's the same
style but it's night and day for me more
immersive it's the same same thing you
say about into the spider vers AC cross
SPID vers it's the same style but it's
one's more defined and Rich and and more
depth they've Advanced it with that time
and it makes a world of difference I'm
in love with this season I think this is
going to be you know if if they keep
going at like you know 1 three and four
caliber two is not bad but like two
feels more like season one yeah uh if
they keep going at this level this will
be in my like second third like I I see
the Marvel the quality as like you know
first tier is for me like winter soldier
guardians Guardians 3 Spider-Man um
three but then tier two is the good
stuff like you know the the captain
America first avenger the the stuff
that's like solid but I I don't find
myself re-watching it as much and then
there's the stuff that I've I've been
like oh no we're falling like things
have gone ay like your love and thunder
like your uh in my case Doctor Strange
and to me this is going to land right in
that sweet like second tier of like this
is really good I'm so actually glad it
exists it emboldens these characters I
won't watch it as often but I'm really
glad it's here yeah I think I think uh
the one and wonder which one I might
rank this about the Christmas one yeah
you got really into the Downey of it I
was surpr I [__] love Christmas that
honestly that honestly surprised the
hell out of me how great um how great of
a job I thought they did with getting
Tony Stark whoever voicing him has to
has to go past an impression right
because they can't just play a Downey
they have to play Tony which is not
Downey yeah I liken it to when a
character makes like when Kevin Conor
had to do Batman or when um Yuri has to
be Spider-Man you know they have to
really make it their own they might have
their Inspirations and it might be but
it has to be their character but it has
to be their character and then even
though they're like yeah we have to have
you be the Robert dony junor version
yeah and this one he's harder spot
because he's got to be playing the
universes blank as his own he's not just
showing up to do a few lines right which
is like you know Josh broland show off
for one line cool that was exciting but
like that was this is a full Arc but
they had this guy show up and I imagine
as the same actor to do lines in the
first season and he has to be a full on
character who's ing this episode with
purpose and intention and motivation you
know what you're right I think that
slightly Inspire other characters I'm
going to put that slightly above
Christmas now too so for me it's 1 four3
two and oh yeah yeah me too yeah I think
the Dynamics were great too between him
and Valkyrie and grandm being like an an
actual villain as opposed to just like a
funny Jeff Goldblum guy I got I got to
see the character of
grandmas versus I was watch you're just
watching Jeff go like like it's you love
him but you're also like Jeff you're
happy Jeff goblins here also the
valkyrie element you brought up during
the episode I really enjoy that we got
some demon in the bottle as an external
reference and this is when he's still
drinking so he had those drinks but I
love that they're acknowledging how
similar those characters are parallel so
yeah this is my second favorite episodes
I agree with you now I think the part
and even him connecting with do you hear
that COI do you hear when you're doing
that you hear how [__] annoying the
people love
it you're just so comfortable you're
going to scratch away at your microphone
how you guys doing it's Christmas you
can hear it can't you can't you hear it
how's your
Christmas we have the same mic have the
same headphones just hanging could hear
it can
you this is what happens when we're this
deep someone has a la mic and they're
scratching away at just hanging
out this is what inevitably happen I'm
trying to talk is that Us Frozen is that
Us Frozen that's how long we've been
screen recording
um and and with uh
Gamora they even acknowledged the
charact even as I was watching it I was
like you just keep bringing up her
father that's her only character and
then the show the episode I was like oh
that's the point that's all she talks
about who are you and how Tony Stark has
affected her identity excellent yeah
this is all the stuff we've been having
problems with the movies not doing and I
and I and I hate to keep taking Jabs at
some of the movies but it is why we
can't just go oh it's fine it's a
blockbuster oh it's fine it's a Marvel
movie yeah people that don't even
realize why they aren't enjoying it as
much yeah this is what we're missing
it's these relationships it's knowing
the characters it's how they relate to
each other it's the metaphors for your
own life while watching it a lot of that
is missing and it's been replaced with
some of the stuff that's more
heavy-handed that isn't Landing so this
is delightful and a lot of the time I
find myself kind of sinking into my
chair because I'm like ah damn it
they're going to be doing what I don't
like about what if season one and then
they don't and then they turn they don't
yeah then I'm like oh they actually they
acknowledge so I feel like they actually
Beyond just improving their animation it
really seems like they learned their
lesson on what went wrong with a lot of
the storytelling to not make it
impactful and I hope the word of mouth
on this movie spreads and people real on
the on the show spreads and people are
like oh you know what this season's
actually worth people's time because and
I do think the day and date release is
good I now that I'm seeing them like
this is exciting to watch every day yeah
I know or all at once when you have cuz
you have to cuz you got to edit them and
have them release day day yeah that too
just us in a cage for 5 hours all righty
guys what do what four I think it was
four all right guys well thank you so
much for being here subscribe leave a
like Merry Christmas what do you think
about this episode see us for
[Music]
five